da kann uns geoengineering retten vor
dem klimawandel der existiert und immer
weiter voranschreitet daran gibt es ja
tragischerweise keinen zweifel inwieweit
können wir ihnen mit herkömmlichen ideen
wie etwa dem ausbau erneuerbarer
energien noch bei kommen gar nicht mehr
dafür ist es viel zu spät das sagen
einige experten ihre ansätze sind krass
und kurios zugleich denn sie wollen
gezielt in das weltweite klimageschehen
eingreifen das stichwort geo engineering
mit hightech gegen den klimawandel also
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und ich beantworte die frage
sind wir noch zu retten jetzt den klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
sonnenschirme im all oder künstliche
vulkanausbrüche das sind nur zwei der
vielen ansätze des forschungsbereiches
namens geoengineering gemeint sind damit
gezielte eingriffe der menschen in das
klimageschehen wir haben hier schon ab
und zu darüber berichtet das ziel die
strahlungsbilanz der erde zu
beeinflussen oder die atmosphärische co2
konzentration zu senken um den
menschengemachten klimawandel zu
kompensieren oder zumindest
abzuschwächen und die konkreten ansätze
und projekte klingen nicht nur beim
ersten eindruck kurios und kraß sondern
sie haben es echt in sich dabei sind die
diskussion um das geo-engineering alles
andere als neu vor allem in den 60er
jahren wurden viele projekte ideen ins
spiel gebracht beispielsweise dachte man
darüber nach zehn wasserstoffbomben
unter dem eismeer zu zünden der dampf
der explosionswolke würde in der oberen
atmosphäre gefrieren und so die
wärmestrahlung reduzieren der erhoffte
effekt eine klimaverbesserung auf der
gesamten erde durch veränderung der
luftzirkulation doch wirklich zu ende
gedacht sind solche ideen meist nicht
meist nicht mehr als theoretische
konstrukte sind sie und wie sollte es
auch anders sein es gibt wohl kaum etwas
komplexeres als das weltweite
klimageschehen physik chemie und so
weiter und so fort spielen da rein und
so waren und sind die tatsächlichen
auswirkungen der jeweiligen projekte
meist absolut nicht vorhersehbar und
genau hier setzt die kritik an werden
bestehende risiken ignoriert gefährden
solche ideen das gesamte leben auf der
erde und untergraben sie die
herkömmlichen ansätze
treibhausgasemissionen zu reduzieren
bereits vor zehn jahren hatte der
klimawissenschaftler alan robock eine
liste zu den gefahren des geo
engineerings erstellt und seine dort
aufgeführten risiken bezüglich umwelt um
klimasystem sind auch heute noch mehr
als aktuell
unvorstellbar seien die folgen die
menschliches oder technisches versagen
mit sich bringen würden zudem befürchtet
robot dass durch solche projekte die
bereitschaft sinkt co2 durch andere
maßnahmen zu reduzieren zudem stellt er
auf die frage nach einer übernationalen
kontrolle
denn wer sonst könne ausschließen dass
die ideen für militärischen zwecken
missbraucht würden
doch wie soll sich solch ein weltweites
kontrollgremium finden lassen wenn doch
einzelne staaten interessenskonflikte
haben die gegebenenfalls unvereinbar
sind heißt im klartext welches land darf
bestimmen wie warm es konkret werden
soll
wie viele es regnen soll und wieviel
sonnenstunden es geben soll
rohbock hat verschiedene szenarien am
computer durchgespielt und errechnet
dass sich die globale
durchschnittstemperatur durch den
einsatz von geoengineering tatsächlich
senken lassen würde
doch die nebeneffekte sind fatal
der sommer monsun in indien und china
beispielsweise der überlebenswichtig für
die bauern dort ist würde beeinträchtigt
es würde wohl weniger regen dort fallen
und auch andere geo engineering projekte
würden wohl fatale auswirkungen mit sich
bringen dazu noch ein konkretes beispiel
ein astronomie team der university of
arizona beschäftigt sich mit dem
themenbereich geo engineering und will
den klimawandel auf der erde bekämpfen
indem zwischen der sonne und der erde so
etwas aufgespannt wird wie ein
gigantischer sonnenschirm konkret
schlagen sie siliziumscheiben vor die
die einstrahlung der sonne um knapp zwei
prozent reduzieren sollen 16 millionen
dünne siliziumscheiben müssten dafür mit
hilfe elektromagnetischer kanonen ins
all geschossen werden an dem punkt wo
sich die anziehungskraft von erde und
sonne aufheben würden sie sich dann auf
rein und eine art sonnensegel bilden
doch diese idee steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen zum einen wäre dies
natürlich mit gigantischen kosten
verbunden zum anderen sind die risiken
auch da kaum abzuwägen modellrechnung
sagen voraus dass sich die toten durch
solch ein projekt abkühlen könnten
arktis und antarktis könnten dagegen
trotzdem wärmer werden und was würde
solch ein projekt bahn bringt eine menge
risiken aber nicht einmal 100 erfolg und
falls ihr jetzt denkt dass nur eine
kleine zahl vielleicht etwas
durchgedrehter wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sich mit diesem thema
dem thema des geo engineerings
beschäftigt falsch gedacht selbst die
deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft dfg hat
schon im mai 2013 ein entsprechendes
projekt in angriff genommen doch auch
hier mahnt man zur zurückhaltung in
einer offiziellen stellungnahme heißt es
dass die bisherige forschung zu diesem
thema stark auf die technischen
möglichkeiten von climate engineering
ausgerichtet war
die forschung sollte aber die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen
für eine bewertung von vor und
nachteilen unterschiedlicher maßnahmen
des kleinen engineering schaffen dabei
stellt das nur sehr beschränkte wissen
über mögliche unerwünschte nebeneffekte
eine wichtige forschungslücke datum
diese zu schließen müssten
forschungsteams aus verschiedenen
bereichen einbezogen werden
beispielsweise aus politik wirtschaft
recht und technik auch die position der
deutschen bundesregierung zum geo
engineering ist klar
man setze weiterhin auf klimaschutz und
die minderung von treibhausgasemissionen
sowie ihre anpassungsmaßnahmen konkrete
geo engineering projekte dagegen
verfolge man nicht viele andere
regierungen dieser welt haben dagegen
noch nicht ihre offizielle position zum
thema öffentlich gemacht doch auch in
china beispielsweise forschen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mit staatlicher unterstützung dazu wie
sich das klima das durch geo engineering
verändert wurde auswirken würde konkret
sind hier noch keine versuche im freien
geplant was das geo-engineering betrifft
halten die meisten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler und auch
regierungschefs dieser erde aber für
deutlich zu früh solche techniken
tatsächlich umzusetzen sie seien zu
wenig erforscht und die auswirkungen zu
krass dennoch steht auch fest dass
solche ideen nicht gleich von vornherein
als mittel gegen die schlimmsten folgen
der globalen erwärmung auszuschließen
sind sagt zum beispiel auch david kies
von der harvard university der seit 25
jahren zum themenfeld des geo
engineerings forscht er möchte
schwefeldioxid im großen stil in die
stratosphäre sprühen
denn die partikel könnten das
sonnenlicht reflektieren so dass die
temperatur auf der erde gesenkt würde
diese methode das sogenannte solar
radiation management ist also quasi an
künstlicher vulkan ausbruch 1991
passierte dies auf natürliche art und
weise als ein philippinischer vulkan 17
millionen tonnen schwefel partikel in
die stratosphäre schleuderte die
durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde
sank damals und knapp ein halbes grad
der mit kies ist sich sicher die
bisherigen forschungsergebnisse weisen
darauf hin dass eine kleine menge
wohldosiertes geoengineering weniger
riskant ist als wenn wir es nicht machen
die mehrheit der menschen auf der welt
würde davon profitieren
aber natürlich müssen gleichzeitig die
treibhausgasemissionen reduziert werden
komme was wolle seien die methode sei
kostengünstig einige milliarden dollar
pro jahr werden angesetzt doch das
eigentliche problem wird damit nicht
behoben die treibhausgase in der
atmosphäre werden nicht weniger kritiker
dieser idee befürchten dass durch diesen
ansatz die ozonschicht beschädigt würde
doch krieges lässt sich nicht abbringen
noch in diesem jahr will er seine idee
erstmals in der praxis umsetzen mit
hilfe eines ballons will er in 25
kilometern höhe artikel versprühen etwas
schwefeldioxid und aluminium dann wieder
zu meinen erforschen inwieweit diese
tatsächlich die ozonschicht angreifen
zum anderen sollen sensoren messen wie
stark die partikel die sonnenstrahlen
reflektieren
gefahren sieht in seinem vorhaben nicht
die auswirkungen des experiments auf die
stratosphäre seien vergleichbar mit dem
einminütigen flug eines
passagierflugzeugs wenn er als erster
neues zum thema geo engineering und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp
dafür gibt's hier den link dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt über mich in der redaktion von
krieg so mitmachen und mehr themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen was hier bei
pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das aber mit genau der glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken geoengineering
gegen klimawandel da geht es konkret um
co2 recycling ansonsten bis dann
flattern
[Musik]